foreign
[Music]
briefing for Wednesday February 22nd I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
payments for ransomware attacks fell
sharply last year according to Federal
officials cyber security analysts and
blockchain firms as many listeners know
ransomware payments are like the digital
equivalent of Hostage payments hackers
take control of computer systems until
they are paid a fee often in
cryptocurrencies these attacks have
crippled private companies hospitals
schools and public infrastructure so the
decline in payments is seen as
significant in the fight against these
hacking groups joining me to discuss how
this drop came about and what comes next
in the fight against cyber criminals is
our cyber security reporter Robert
McMillan hi Bob thanks for coming back
on the show hi Zoe great to be here
so payments to ransomware hackers are
down but how far down are we talking and
is this just about the amounts paid out
or our overall attacks down too well I
don't think the attacks are down but
what's happening is the results of the
attacks is changing the firm chain
analysis which kind of tracks the
payments to ransomware groups says that
the percentage amount paid to them went
down 40 percent in 2022 from 2021 so
that's a pretty big drop and what that
means is
the ransomware people may be trying
they're certainly trying just as hard as
ever to try and infect companies and
then to shake them down and extort them
but companies aren't paying as often as
they were another firm that we talked to
Cove wear says that the average amount
that it's paying to Ransom our groups
actually dropped year over year again by
a similar figure what went from four
hundred thousand dollars per event to
three hundred thousand dollars in 2022
so you can see the amount being paid to
them is going down the amount per
incident is going down and it's putting
a little bit of a squeeze on The
ransomware Operators well what if law
enforcement said about this drop oh they
want to take credit for it right because
so in 2021 there was this colonial
pipeline ransomware incident which
really got the attention of everyone in
the United States right up to the
president and so at that point the law
enforcement agencies the FBI Department
of Justice really put ransomware in
their crosshairs and they've actually
done a fair bit since that incident to
try and push back on the problem so the
most remarkable story around that I
think over the last year was this Hive
takedown where they got access to the
secret servers used by The ransomware
Operators and they got the encryption
keys that they were selling to their
victims and just gave them away for free
to all the the victims that they
estimate the ransomware group have lost
about 130 million dollars in potential
profits from this operation I think the
Strategic move that the government is
doing here is they're just trying to
make it a less profitable business to be
in because let's be honest these
ransomware groups they really do operate
like businesses it does sound like some
of these big announcements that we've
heard over the last year high profile
charges and arrests you know the kind of
groups has played a role what
does that mean for these ransomware
groups which as you say often operate
like businesses the truth is the thing
that's had the biggest effect I think is
really boring it's just that companies
are getting better at backing up their
systems and being able to recover when
they're all shut down by ransomware it's
thankless work until you get to the
point where you're infected and then you
can bounce back you can just ignore
their demands and come back online so
what that's doing to the ransomware
operators is it's making it a little bit
harder for them to just to have this
money making machine that they've
operated for years so what they're doing
is they're looking for new ways of
getting in and they're looking for new
types of companies to in fact ones that
maybe aren't as prepared as the
traditional victims of ransomware and in
some cases they might even be moving to
other types of crime like other types of
financial fraud so are you saying that
these ransomware our groups are having
to change their business models a little
bit we talked to one researcher who said
that this group it used to be called
Conti but it's sort of a group of cyber
criminals that have been around for a
long time and traditionally they had one
way of getting onto everybody's networks
it was really successful but with the
attention being paid to ransomware they
were just they were having a harder time
getting that initial infection getting
onto your network where they could
install the ransomware so they set up
all these call centers where they would
send out emails and you'd get like a
disturbing looking email and maybe it
would say you owed money or something
like that and you'd call this call
center and the person at the call center
would try to talk you into installing
some software on your computer that
would ultimately allow the ransomware
people to get ransomware on your
company's Network so that was like a
business model change that they did and
it didn't work out like they weren't
making money doing this the call center
people weren't talking people into
installing the software enough and so
they actually had playoffs there they
shut down these call centers so big
picture then I mean is this a sign that
the tables have turned on ransomware
attacks
oh I don't know I mean I would I would
really not predict the end of ransomware
is that too hopeful it's not the kind of
bet that you'd ever make money on I
don't think but it shows that there are
some things that could be done this was
like a pretty amazing business for the
criminals you know if you think about it
ransomware just a few years ago maybe
six or seven years ago the average
ransomware demand was like hundreds of
dollars and then it was tens of
thousands of dollars and now kovar is
saying it's in the range of three
hundred thousand dollars there's been
this great inflation in what they've
been able to ask for and until 2021
until that Colonial event there wasn't
like a lot of pushback there wasn't a
lot of pressure on them and now they're
facing some realities their business is
not going to be as profitable as it was
so I think that there are many entities
in the world that would like to continue
to make it more difficult for them to do
business you know companies just stop
paying if they get their act together
and they can recover when they're
infected and just restore everything for
backups instead of having to pay for a
decryption key then I don't think it's
going to go away but it could become
less of a problem all right that's our
cyber security reporter Robert McMillan
thanks for joining us Bob thanks Zoe and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
if you want more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
foreign
[Music]